foreign
[Music]
complain we get another white and we get
a strong opponent parthy chess from
India and another Sicilian awesome so
this is an elephant day and this will
probably be a separate YouTube video so
people watching on YouTube uh I'm
recording this right after playing the
previous elephant game which was its own
video that was the 20 move win where we
won the queen at the end the same night
hopefully we get another convincing win
all right once again we Face D5
once again we Face D5 and this time we
Face the line that I recommended for
black so this is actually kind of cool
this is the line that I recommend to
most people against the elephant for
several reasons I think objectively it's
quite good white can obtain a slight
Advantage if he knows a load of theory I
will admit I'm pretty Rusty on the
theory here myself but even if white
plays all the correct moves you get a
pretty enterprising and unbalanced
position so in terms of playing against
the elephant for a win Knight F6 is
really second to none and most people
who play the elephant don't really study
this line it falls through the cracks
and black can definitely get an
advantage if white doesn't handle this
accurately so the point of Knight F6 of
course is to recapture with the Knight
which is a more convenient way to
recapture the pawn
the downside may appear to be that white
has C4 but as you already hopefully have
picked up from multiple Speed Run games
C4 is not a solution to White's problems
because black responds with E6 and in
the event of the trade black gets total
Monopoly over the key Central squares
and full compensation for the pawn and
I'll explain that reiterate that after
the game
if we will check the elephant Bible
after this game because I will fully
confess that I am blanking on what their
recommended line is it might be a check
on A4 I think it is a check on A4 but
that's not what we're gonna play here I
do know a very practical line I've
played it in Blitz and although black
can equalize with very accurate play it
does pose a lot of problems at least
initially and we will test our
opponent's knowledge of this line the
move that we're going to start with is
Bishop to B5 check which should be on
your radar as a very natural move
because it forces a piece to land on D7
and as a consequence of that the contact
between the queen and the D5 Pawn has
been severed black plays Knight bd7
which is the correct move which is the
correct move and now now that the Knight
is occupying an awkward square and the
black Bishop will have a hard time
getting out this is when we choose to
open up the center so this is where
rather than trying to cling to this Pawn
with the move C4 which is a very
theoretical line black responds with A6
and then a quick B5 very dangerous for
white and rather than trying something
like Queen F3 to which black can again
respond with A6 and ultimately the
Knight will jump out to E5 it'll have
the opposite effect now is the time when
we strike with D4 now we strike with D4
so we open up the center
obviously if black plays Knight takes D5
then we can capture the pawn on C5 the
pawn cannot be recaptured because the
Knight is pinned and the Knight on D5 is
suddenly going to be hanging DC is a
discovered attack
if black plays C takes D4 then we can
recapture with the queen Our Queen is
almost shielded by The Pawn on D5 which
acts kind of like an umbrella so the
queen on Z4 is not going to be easy to
attack and unless black is very very
precise here it's easy to end up a pawn
down for no compensation I don't even
fully remember how black is supposed to
play this which is kind of a good thing
A6 here might be the best move we'll
check all of this with the engine and
with the book after the game so hold all
of your opening thoughts this is
definitely a a gap that we that we need
to fill from both sides
yeah because if you kind of just
visually look at the position after CD
Queen D4 it looks bad for black right it
doesn't look like black is anywhere near
recovering the pawn on D5 and once we do
that then C4 becomes a lot uh more
palatable of a possibility because once
the center is opened the move C4 does
not contain any downsides whereas
playing it here with the pawn still
sitting on D2 that's where the problems
come from because after C4 E6 and the
trade that pawn becomes a backward pawn
and that correspondingly the square on
D4 is a big Outpost that black can use
for their Knight
okay so black continues to ponder his
next move wood asks after Knight takes
D5 DC E6 does white play B4 I wouldn't
play B4 I think there there was C6 in
that position but we'll explore that
after the game our opponent has played
A6 which I'm 99 sure is in fact the
correct move now Bishop A4 would be
too stubborn and counterproductive
because it would merely enable black to
expand on the queen side with B5 more
importantly it would give black the
fianchetto square for free for the light
squid Bishop so definitely not Bishop A4
definitely not Bishop C4 again the point
is not to cling to the extra Pawn it's
to use the pawn as a bargaining chip and
gain a lead in development in return for
that pawn which is currently an extra
Pawn so by recapturing it black simply
equalizes the material so we make a
modest move we make a modest move
those of you who've seen all of the
speedrun videos might remember that you
have a similar kind of idea which I
recommended against I think it's called
the Portuguese variation of the
Scandinavian where you throw in the
check on B5 and then drop the bishop all
the way back to E2
why not D3 because again that destroys
the connection between the queen and the
pawn bishop D3 black can capture on D4
and what we do not want is an isolated
Queen Pawn position where Black's Knight
is already blockading the square in
front of it instead we drop back to E2
and we simply continue developing our
pieces I think against Narayanan I
played this in a rapid Blitz game
I think I might have tried an early C4
and D5 and I did manage to get a good
position in that game
so let me think for a second what do we
want to do here
of course the the sort of natural move
is Knight F3 but I do I really do like
the look of C4 here driving the pawn
down to D5 kind of benoni style
um there there
I know there's a lot of theory in that
position let's try C4 let's try to be as
principled as possible because we will
not get another chance to play C4 and E5
why not because if Black's Pawn had
already been on E6 here then the move D5
would be completely counterproductive
because after the trade our Pawn on D5
would be a Sitting Duck and black would
pick it off with the knights and the
queen now of course if black plays E6 we
invite that because we take on E6 and we
ruin black structure I think white is a
little bit better here okay G6 so our
opponent is playing this kind of like a
benoni we need to develop our pieces
right we've made enough pawn moves to
last us a lifetime I don't think it even
matters what move we start with Knight
C3 Knight F3 not of principal importance
let's start with Knight C3 now let's
bring the other night out to F3 and
let's get our King out of the center
presumably our opponent will do the same
and I think black's position is pretty
unpleasant here now we could also throw
in the move H3 which would be a typical
move that you often see in these types
of positions just covering the G4 square
but I'm not concerned about Knight G4 so
I think it's more important for us to
develop
also uh meriting attention was the move
A4 if you're familiar with uh the benoni
you probably know that B7 B5 is one of
Black's main sources of Queen side
counterplay
um and here as well black could
contemplate the move B5 it's a very
Advanced move because here it involves a
pawn sacrifice kind of benko Gambit
style and I'm not convinced that it's
sound in this position
but you know a Soviet Schoolboy might
have played A4 just to cardinally
prevent the possibility of B5
of course A4 has a certain positional
downsides it weakens the B4 square but
that square is not going to be easy to
occupy there is neither of Black's
Knights will be able to easily make
their way to B4
yeah so black is worse I think because
we've got a space Advantage we've got a
nice Pawn wedge in in the center we've
got clear subsequent development for our
pieces right Bishop can come out to G5
or maybe E3 in order to pressure the
pawn then we can play Queen D2 and our
opponent does indeed play B5 okay I'm
pretty impressed that you know that that
he was able to come up with this idea
because it takes a knowledge of kind of
benko Gambit style Concepts but I'm
pretty skeptical about its soundness
obviously we need to call the bluff
because otherwise we allow the spawn to
get to B4 or we allow black to take on
C4 we might as well accept the sacrifice
we don't need to think about that black
takes back okay so again there's no
question that we're going to take the
pawn on B5
which piece should we capture it with
well I think that question has an
obvious answer Knight takes B5 seems
very awkward to me not only because it
opens up the diagonal for Black's Bishop
but mostly because we take our eyes off
of the D5 Pawn it's entirely possible
that black will ultimately win that pawn
back but we don't want to go down
without a fight and after Knight takes
B5 Knight B6 suddenly we only have one
defender on the pawn and black S3
attackers maybe we could push the pawn
to D6 in that position and kind of make
that work but that just seems like it
goes in the wrong direction Bishop Diggs
B5 a lot more natural keeping the Knight
on its natural square and of course the
bishop could later on dive into C6 and
hit the rook and protect the pawn from a
nice Square now typical in the benko is
to initiate the trade of light squared
Bishops with Bishop A6 this is a move
that you do see very frequently in the
benko but in contrast to the benko which
I'll show after the game so if you're
watching this on YouTube and I don't
know what the Banco Gambit is first of
all you can always pause the video and
just Google it then you'll go down the
rabbit hole and start watching Banco
videos it's a Gambit that occurs after
one D4 and it the mechanism is exactly
the same black plays C5 and then B5 and
it's fallen out of favor at the top
level in recent years white is
considered to be sort of solidly better
several different ways but among Club
players it's still a very dangerous
weapon it's absolutely still playable
and uh the bottom line is that black
develops in return for the pawn long
lasting pressure on the queen side but
here it seems like we've already castled
which is a big Advantage for us we've
already brought our Knights out and
black just doesn't have all that much
stuff going on the queen side the Knight
on D7 is passive
the pawn on C5 is weak this seems like a
seriously inferior benko but in general
not to belabor the point arapono is
taking his time though so
when you hear players or commentators
mention oh this is like a benoni
structure this is a benko I like idea
it's normally it normally refers to some
opening where the idea in question is
more common than in the current opening
like in the Sicilian you rarely see this
type of sacrifice in the benko it
literally revolves around that sacrifice
Bishop B7
okay so what does our opponent want well
probably he wants Knight B6 after which
the four pieces are going to be
attacking the D5 Pawn if we lose that
pawn it's totally not the end of the
world but that might signal the end of
our advantage so what kinds of ideas
come to mind here well let's take a
couple of moments I need to think
my Temptation was the move Bishop C6
right this seemed very tempting to me
because in the event of the trade that
pawn lands on C6 and could even move to
C7 potentially with a fork but after
Bishop C6 black has this weird looking
move Queen B6 which should be pretty
obvious to you because it attacks the
bishop two different ways and in the
event of the trade that Queen fiance on
B7 is actually a very strong piece and
in the benko black often wants the queen
to be precisely there why because it
pressures simultaneously both of White's
weak pawns on D5 and B2 so we're
ultimately helping black get their
pieces where they want want them to go
we should find an alternate way of
meeting the threat of Knight B6 and
that's where the idea of Bishop F4 comes
in Bishop F4 aims to meet Knight B6 with
D6 so this was my first candidate option
my second was very similar Bishop E3
similar mechanism tying black down to
the C5 pawn bishop E3 if Knight B6 and
we capture the pawn on C5 and we have
connected past pawns on the queen side
which is a huge huge asset that could be
converted into victory in the event that
the Queens get traded so Bishop F4 and
Bishop E3 are my two big candidate moves
I like the look of Bishop E3 because
it's a little bit simpler and I'll share
some of my more detailed considerations
after the game
I feel like Bishop B3 might be a little
bit more precise
our opponent immediately opts for
the line in question well we have no
choice but to take on C5 maybe I rushed
maybe bishop C6 here was possible uh
maybe bishop C6 was strong not entirely
sure anyways we'll explore that
afterward Knight takes D5
okay so now we need to navigate the
complexities carefully right because
we've got a lot of pieces on black side
of the board and they're undefended and
you just got to be careful not to
blunder a fork or some for you know it's
not the end of the world everything is
pretty well positioned so in general
right from a large scale bird's eye view
perspective we want to trade pieces we
now have connected past pawns any end
game be it a queen NBA Rook end game is
probably going to be winning for us in
the absence of a compelling reason not
to we should trade pieces minor pieces
Queens whatever we can and I don't see
any reason that we shouldn't start by
trading the ponies by taking the Knight
on D5
Knight takes D5 and now I think we
should essentially continue our campaign
to trade as many minor pieces as
possible and to do it as fast as
possible we have a nice way I think to
pose a nasty little ultimatum to Black
either you give up one of your main
pieces the bishop on G7 or
you drop your knight back and your
pieces become a lot more passive what am
I thinking about here yeah I'm really
eyeing the move Bishop D4 and it seems
very appetizing let's go for it
yeah obvious move
threatening to trade the Bishops and
then black will be saddled also with
sort of weak King which could become
annoying if the Queens remain on the
board
I had to look at a move like Knight to
F4 right because the bishop on B7 is a
pretty intimidating piece and moves like
Knight F4 always need to be considered
but here we actually take on G7 and
we're able to force the Queens off the
board and that resulting end game is far
from an obvious win it might even be a
draw but I feel like with the extra Pawn
we will as long as we're able to keep
Black's initiative at Bay the pawns
should ultimately make their presence
felt
for the sub Calia shirt but we'll think
about it we don't have to grab the
Queens automatically we can also keep
the Queens on the board it's not the end
of the world so yeah our opponent is
thinking of course Knight F6 would avoid
the trade of Bishops but that would be a
positive for us because the Knight would
be brought away from the center and we
could breathe a little bit more easily
rearrange our pieces and ultimately
start pushing our pawns even if it's the
middle game yeah F6 F6 would be music to
my ears honestly maybe it's the best I
don't know maybe F6 and E5 there's a
case to be made for that but it does
seem incredibly weakening E5 whoa what a
move that one I will admit I didn't even
was not on my radar at all
so let's decipher the idea
now Bishop takes E5 is the obvious
recapture
I assume that black wants to take on E5
and after Knight takes E5 bring the
queen down to G5 okay that is what I
assume to be Black's idea and rather
than just immediately panicking and
saying oh okay let's trust our opponent
let's ponder that position for a second
after Queen G5 the danger lies in the
fact that black has pressure on G2 and
black has an attack on the night but I
think we have an ingenious tactical
solution in that position we can force
that Bishop off the board
with the move Bishop C6 right so this is
after takes takes takes Queen G5
there I think we have the move Bishop C6
and if black takes the Knight then we
take the bishop if black takes the
bishop then we recapture with the Knight
black can threaten checkmate with Knight
F4 but it's just a one move threat and I
think we can handily defend against it
with for example Queen F3 and then we
will emerge two pawns up still we won't
be out of the woods black has some
initiative
but it seems to me that Black's
initiative will be dying out in that
situation we can also play Knight takes
E5 but that one I like a lot less
because then black can play the
immediate Knight F4 and our pieces just
kind of get tangled up in the center so
we want to play a little faster here
we're going to leave ourselves with some
time let's play Bishop B5 and call our
opponents Bluff also possible by the way
I just realized was Bishop C5 I
completely missed that move but I
actually like our choice because Bishop
C5 E4 would have been a complete and
utter mess even if we won the exchange
we'll explore that afterward
okay the other thing that I you know
looked at a little bit is whether black
has a fork on these two minor pieces
because both of them are undefended type
1 undefended pieces
but the queen has nowhere to attack both
of them right Queen E8 obviously
punished the queen
so that's the other thing that I made
sure of
other than Queen G5 I don't see anything
even remotely scary maybe Knight F4 but
obviously then we can take the Queens
off the board
and with two extra pawns we should be
fine as long as we avoid G3 which runs
into Maiden one very common blunder I
think we'll be fine
so Queen G5 Bishop B5 to C6 hopefully
everybody understands the logic behind
that move
we attack the bishop on B7 and if the
bishop takes we recapture with the
Knight
and as a nice bonus does anybody see
what we're threatening in that resulting
position it's probably not going to
matter because black will play Knight F4
anyway
but if black for example plays Rook ac-8
there
and we have a sexy little tactic Queen
takes D5 yeah very nice and then 97
check picks up the queen on D5
and I think perhaps our opponent has
spotted Bishop C6 and is now trying to
figure out an alternate
yeah but it's just there's just not
enough Firepower on the board
we don't have any weaknesses and it's
important not to be scared of so Queen
G5 Bishop C6 trade the move Knight F4
there I think would be scary to a lot of
players and it should be scary right
when a queen in the Knight is attacking
that by definition is scary the queen
and the Knight the strongest tandem in
chess but a main threat in and of itself
isn't scary we could just bring our
Queen up to F3 black has no other
attackers whereas our Rook is near the
king our Knight could easily jump back
into the center
and we could push black snide away with
a well-timed G3
yeah Knight F4 here I've been thinking
about what we want to do if he plays
Knight F4 because the queen trade the
funny thing there is that Black's
initiative does last into the end game
for three reasons first of all the G2
Pawn is hanging second of all black has
the D file and The Rook at infiltrate to
D2 third of all remember these minor
pieces are both undefended they're on
the same rank which means you should
always be aware of a move like Rook to
D5
which incidentally we might still have
Bishop C6 to the rescue but we don't
wanna
engage in these complications so Knight
F4 I'm actually more inclined to play a
different move not to take the queen
what other moves are available to us
after Knight F4 yeah I think Tom o'
Bedlam got it nothing has to change just
because the Queens are staring at each
other we can still play the move that we
were planning to play anyway
no no no don't play F3 because then
Queen B6 picks up the bishop instead
after Knight F4 I think we can just
still play Bishop C6 and we can still
trade the Bishops and if black wants to
trade Queens Be Our Guest you know and
we get the D file
so after Knight F4 Bishop C6 Bishop
takes C6 Knight takes C6 if black plays
Queen G5 there it simply transposes into
the position that we've already been
analyzing
otherwise the queen doesn't have any
other great squares Queen F6 we can go
Queen F3 there what should black play
asks Kavita I don't know I think black
is in big trouble I think black has
virtually no compensation for two pawns
I would probably go Queen G5 and stick
with the initial idea
probably I would go Queen G5 Bishop C6
trade go Knight F4 and after Queen F3
play a move like rook ae8 and basically
just go all in and try to create
something on the king side
but yeah I think black is unless I'm
seriously Mis evaluating something or
missing a concrete resource of some sort
some computer-ish idea
I think black is borderline lost I do
see a crazy idea
that I'll reveal after the game unless
our opponent plays this move
and queen F6 and that was the move that
was the move
uh that I had in mind
so the idea is you're luring white into
Knight D7 which appears to win The
Exchange
what is Black's idea after Knight D7
well van black plays Queen G5 notice
that Bishop C6 is no longer possible but
you might think I don't I just take the
Rook but if you take the Rook White's
Knight jumps out to E3 with a double
attack right this is a discovery against
G2 and White's Queen is under Fire there
I think white just collapses and loses
the queen so after Knight D7 Queen G5
that position seems very tactical and
I'm not sure that it's worth going for
it especially with a low time situation
unless we find something specific after
Knight D7 Queen G5 so I'm gonna take a
couple moments here and think about this
because this is a high stakes position
have an idea I'm just double checking it
57 Queen G5 I'm eyeing the move Queen to
F3 which is a very risky move because
we're putting the queen right under The
Bishop's nose
but I don't see any effective
discoveries there and I think everything
might be under control they're there
there let's say black moves The Rook
then we can jump back to C5 with the
Knight and hit the bishop where it hurts
yeah I think
we will go precisely for this idea let's
go Knight D7 let's go Knight t7
and now we're just quickly gonna play
this move not Knight takes Rook because
of Knight E3 but instead we bring our
Queen to the rescue this might be a
blunder I might be blundering something
so the key concept here is why would a
move like this not occur to a lot of
players well because you're putting the
queen where you're not supposed to put
it but remember that pins are often
two-way streets this is what people
might not understand yes the more
valuable piece is usually the more
vulnerable piece
because the stakes are less for black
but still the bishop on B7 is just as
undefended as the queen is so this is
dangerous for the queen but it's also
dangerous for the bishop the Knight
can't really move because the bishop is
undefended that concept is important it
allows you to understand the value of a
move like Queen F3 is it risky yes could
it be very rewarding also yes
also Queen G3 is a safe move that we
could play virtually regardless of
Black's response but we could also go
for more depending on where the Rook
moves I'm assuming the black will move
his Rook
yeah but Rook A7 is a very ingenious
move to defend the bishop but there I
think we can probably take the Rook on
f8 I think Rook A7 we already can take
because if white black plays Knight E3
there
how should we respond in that position
who can uh keep their composure Knight
Rook a seven Knight takes f8 and Knight
E3 we ignore the Knight because then we
get checkmated
where do we move our Queen
yeah we just play Queen three there
because we're already up a rook so all
we need to do is defend against the
immediate threat
yeah Harold Lloyd brings up a great
Point great tactical eye if black plays
Rook C8 there is Rook a to D1 with the
threat of a double capture on D5 with
Knight F6 check to follow but I feel
like that's a little bit of one movitus
blackened defend against that and I
don't know if we want to burn our Tempo
on that threat
I do think Rook fc8 is Black's best move
in fact I'm pretty confident because it
prevents Knight C5 so I think black
should play Rook fc8 but then we've got
time right Brook fc8 black does not have
any threats so we can make a general
improving move potentially such as even
a move like Rook fe1 could be considered
Rook FCA played all right let's think
give me 30 seconds
so I've I've had a couple candidate
moves here
and they all stem from the same
in general
sentiment which is that white is not in
a hurry I don't see any threats for
black surprisingly enough so we have the
time and the luxury to make an improving
move and what does it mean to make an
improving move here well we have the
move Queen G3 which tries to get the
Queens off the board I like the move
Queen G3 I think it might be the most
practical option but we don't have to
rush with Queen G3 we can play that move
next so a move that I also like is Rook
after E1 bringing the Rook to an open
file getting the Rook into the game the
problem there might be the move for Rook
to C2 so that's what I'm struggling with
right now
I'm calculating a crazy line Rook fe1
Rook C2 rookie five
trying to give the Rook up for two
pieces Rook C1 check Bishop F1 oh my
gosh it gets pretty crazy there I don't
really want that
rookie D1 actually the more I look at it
the more I like it
okay I have another idea
A4 is also very interesting just pushing
the pawn
let's go A4
which is the most anticlimactic move
ever
it took three minutes for me to generate
this move and I'll explain stuff in a
lot greater detail after the game I'll
sort of walk you through all my
calculations
but right now I don't want to lose on
time the tldr is that I want this bishop
to be defended because if the Knight
moves away I don't want to deal with the
Queen's attack on the bishop I want to
be able to focus on the king side also
this bishop is crucial because it
defends the Knight and the Knight is
kind of stuck in Black's territory so
the last thing we would want is to lose
the bishop because then we might lose
the Knight
so this allows me to focus on the king
side and on improving my position now we
might even sacrifice the B2 Pawn okay
black finds this move now there's Knight
B6 here which is interesting but I had
my eyes on Queen G3
now we're gonna try to trade
now black doesn't have to opt for the
trade
but if he doesn't then that means the
attack is over and then we can finally
focus on bringing our pieces into the
game there is a very subtle tactical
line that I spent like two minutes
calculating which occurs if Buck takes
the queen and then takes the pawn on B2
which I'm assuming our opponent will
and maybe it doesn't work I mean it's
it's it's very tenuous and he does
and we will
and we drop our Knight back that was
that was the move that I spent so long
searching for but I actually am seeing a
way for black to dodge the loss of
material we're almost winning
wow there's a crazy idea for black hair
that I did overlook
now we'll still have winning chances
here no matter what obviously because
we're up a pawn
I thought this won the game because the
bishop is attacked and if black defends
it well then we take it and play Bishop
C6 forking the rook and the Knight on D5
but
I won't say this until black moves
and black finds it so Bishop C6 I missed
Rook A5 counter-attacking the Knight
okay let's not panic let's let's figure
out a way to keep the pressure going
something here I just don't have time to
figure it out some sort of Magnus would
find a very strong motor in an instant I
like the look of even Rook fc1 very
simple move yeah just Rook fc1 looks
very very strong here too let's play it
just improving the position
and obviously we now reinforce the
threat of Bishop C6 because the Knight
is protected also we're keeping an eye
on Rook takes P5 it's very important
that the Rooks defend each other let's
not move a rook off of the first rank
that okay Bishop F5 that might have been
a blunder because let's consider Bishop
C6 I'm assuming that our opponent wants
Rook d8 but does anybody see what move
we have in that position that might
finally topple Black's resistance Bishop
C6 Rook d8 the rook and the queen
they're not particularly good Defenders
because they're easy pieces to attack we
have Knight C5 to B7 the bishop and the
Knight are the heroes of this game
they're constantly rearranging to form
new threats this is I think the move
black finally overlooks
and this might do it
this might do it only 28 moves it's
crazy how short this game has been and
how much has happened I think this ends
it
black is out of squares okay and our
opponent is desperation now let's be
precise don't grab the Knight you know
it's like you're grabbing the first type
of candy that you see try to be accurate
it's much more accurate to take the Rook
here
and after Rook takes B7 to return to C6
and pick off the Knight then we'll be up
a rook and the game ends very nice GG I
I have to come our opponent played a
fantastic game this was this was close
and there's a lot to analyze so let's
try to do it as carefully as we can
so first order of business is for us to
educate ourselves on this line and I am
going to grab our elephant Bible
now note that the second reliable source
on the elephant is the new chessable
course that came out by again ghouli
and uh qasim John of that you can find
on chess well I could check that one as
well but we will limit ourselves to the
book squeezing the Sicilian by Alexander
califman yeah Knight F6 Queen A4 I was
my hunch was correct
yeah McQueen A4 check this is the move
that is recommended by califman
black might have unnecessary
difficulties to regain his Pawn on D5
Bishop D7
is the only move that they no that is
not the only move they give there's
Bishop D7 and there's Knight bd7
obviously Queen D7 does not deserve any
analysis if Bishop D7
then the the queen is dropped back to B3
this is a nice Square Queen B6 is
virtually forced otherwise black is not
going to be able to even try to regain
the pawn they also give Queen C7 just
Bishop C4 so you actually load the
pieces up on this pawn and it's not just
the extra Pawn that's the problem black
can't move like this Pawn is restricting
lacks development in a big way this is
plus minus Queen E5 checks simply 92 and
black is already losing because D4 is
coming next
so Queen B6 here is the main line and
now you keep the tension with Bishop C4
they give Knight A6 the only way to
develop now we develop as well and black
brings the Knight around to C7 very
typical maneuver in this line and here
they give the move d4
so the general concept here is similar
you wait for the appropriate moment to
open up the center
and when you open up the center you are
giving the pawn back but as a
consequence you're going to get a big
initiative in the middle game or in the
end game in this case
Queen takes B3 a takes B3 black is able
to win the pawn back CD Knight T4
they also
mention the move D6 giving the pawn away
but ruining black spawn structure it's
an interesting alternative
but in their main line we get this end
game
and white is slightly better no question
about it because White's pieces are very
nicely placed black is cramped White's
got you know obvious control of the a
file in a very mobile Pawn Mass on the
queen side
this is the game Hammer coolav against
Guerrero Spain 2008. so for example if
black plays E6 here
I think a good way to follow up
would be to get this Knight around not
to D2 that's not the destination right
this is a Frankfurt airport move
where is the night going it's going to
F3 to support its brother and
potentially also jump into E5 white
could also contribute to the pressure
with B4
so definitely
a very practical line there and if black
plays Knight bd7 which I think is more
popular then they give the rare moves
between B3 again defending the pawn and
this is easy to remember because you
play Queen B3 against both Bishop D7 and
Knight D7 if black plays Knight to B6
then we deliver the check now with a
bishop Bishop D7 and C4 black plays E6
but now E6 no longer comes with the same
effect because after de black has to
recapture it with the pawn and that is
incredibly awkward if black has to
recapture with a pawn then there's no
more compensation Bishop D6 this is some
game that they're giving brnovich yunzel
2018 so pretty recent game
takes takes Queen E3 Queen E7 D3
castles Queen E2 and they give plus
minus yeah black is virtually no
compensation because he himself has a
backward Pawn on E6 finally if black
plays
move 5 G6
trying to just fee and ghetto then we
develop our pieces modestly with Bishop
E2 avoid Bishop C4 because that walks
right into Knight P6
castles castles
if Knight B6 again it's time for C4 and
if B6 then D3 Bishop B7 again we play C4
and again if black plays E6 then he has
to recapture it with the pawn
and here they claim after Knight G4
Black's pieces are very active in
White's defense is not easy at all
um ooh so I apologize this line
apparently equalizes for black so their
Improvement on move nine is the
immediate C4 white should not lose a
tempo for the move D3 but try instead to
advance D4 at once
Bishop B7 Knight C3 E6 trade oh and
rather than playing D3 you open up the
center immediately with D4 and here they
claim that white is a slight Advantage
takes takes
Knight C5 Queen D1 everything is nicely
defended Knight fe4 Bishop E3 trade
and they claim a slight Advantage for
white white is up a pawn and the central
piece mass is very very compact here so
definitely something that I would
investigate further
but for all intents and purposes this is
absolutely a line that you could play
and expect to get an advantage in
so rather than our move which was Bishop
B5 checks similar idea but you do it
with the queen queen A4 check
and uh against both responses the queen
moves back to B3 if Bishop D7 Queen B3
attacks the pawn I think Bishop D7 is
just a bad move
and here you defend the pawn
but at some point you take the plunge
and you open up the center getting a
better end game
and if black plays Knight bd7 then you
still play Queen B3 and here you do try
to keep your extra Pawn if Knight B6
then you throw in this other check and
then follow up with C4 in order so that
after e6de black cannot recapture with
the bishop
all right I think and and G6 might be
Black's best move but not a lot of
people are gonna know this and now you
develop develop
and then at some point
you protect the pawn with C4 in order
also to get the C3 Square for the Knight
and then you try to go D4 in one Fell
Swoop
so hopefully that was relatively clear
that this is call of Fun's
recommendation against Knight F6
and definitely we can continue playing
this with black I mean very few people
are going to know this especially know
this by heart my Bishop B5 check is
obviously a totally viable alternative
it might even be what they recommend in
the chessable course I don't know I'll
check this after the stream black plays
Bishop Knight bd7 which is correct and
now we open up the center with D4
A6 is definitely the only correct move
for black so once again if black had
played Knight T5 this is Hasty because
here white simply emerges up a pawn and
after E6 I think we can drive this Pawn
down to C6 and make things even worse
for black black has to trade
and in this position I would not grab a
second Pawn because that walks right
into Bishop B7 with a huge initiative
instead I would just develop my pieces
with Knight F3 also because this could
threaten Knight E5 here definitely black
has insufficient compensation no
question about it
after A6 we bring our Bishop back
recaptures on D5 and now I like our
decision to play C4 and D5 I think this
is extremely testing
and I actually think that Black's main
mistake came here I think G6 is natural
as it is might be a serious inaccuracy
after which black is struggling quite a
bit to equalize and I don't think
equality is possible after this move
instead what should black consider doing
immediately this is actually what
happened in my game or in the uh rapid
Chess Championship the one time I played
yeah black actually should go B5
immediately
not E6 this is a terrible structure for
black here white is definitely better
but black should go for the benko style
idea immediately with B5
and after cb5 Black Goes Knight B6 and
the chief difference is that black is
able to win back the pawn on D5 if we
compare this to the situation where our
opponent played B5
which was here what is the difference
well still black should have played
Knight B6
still black should have played Knight B6
and here I also think that black is able
to win back the pawn so the interesting
thing is that if we follow the course of
the game and I did just check this with
the engine I mentioned this during the
game but it might have been worth
spending a tempo maybe after Knight C3
to play the move A4 and prevent black
from playing B5 I really think this was
worth a tempo
somehow I forgot that Knight B6 wins
back the pawn but the most clinical
continuation for black is to not
procrastinate and immediately play B5
and Knight B6
and if white plays B takes A6
I think the simplest is just to
recapture the pawn because this Pawn is
not going anywhere
and after the trade black is gonna win
back the pawn on D5 and I think black is
very close to equalizing here the engine
gives the move Queen E2 hitting the rook
and if the Rook moves away then there is
a very nasty check on B5 so black has to
be very careful here
and apparently the move for black is C4
intercepting the queen Knight C3 Knight
F takes D5
trade on D5 Knight F3 now both sides
develop E6 castles Bishop E7 and this
position is approximately equal white
has a nice passed Pawn but black has
very active pieces the engine gives
zeros so this is indeed the equalizing
line but it's hard I mean you got us
know you gotta know to play B5 and you
gotta know to play Knight B6 so it takes
quite a few accurate moves to equalize
here so definitely you could repeat this
in one of your games and you can expect
to get a good position okay
so in the game our opponent decided to
first develop the king side which I
think is fine once again perhaps A4 was
a little bit more precise from our
perspective to prevent B5 because after
b5c takes B5 definitely a takes B5 is a
very serious mistake it's an automatic
move right it's very natural to
recapture but that allows our Bishop to
jump into a very active square and now
black is too late to go Knight B6
because here we have Bishop C6
protecting the pawn this is the chief
difference if black plays Knight B6
immediately then we're unable to defend
the spawn with our Bishop and again if
we play ba then black can either take on
A6 or in this case I think black can
take on D5 first
and white could end up being worse in a
position like this because Black's
pieces are much more active this is like
a dream benko setup engine gives Queen
C2 and black just recaptures and in this
position apparently white is worse just
because look at the activity that black
has reached I mean white can barely move
a muscle the bishop is tied down to the
pawn the other Pawn is hanging the
rook's coming in this is what you're
trying to avoid on the white side of a
benko structure even though you are
technically up a pawn so Knight B6 did
equalize here apparently white should
play Bishop to E3 counter-attacking the
C5 pawn and now you get some sort of
mass liquidation takes takes takes takes
takes
and if you play Rook B1 then black
simply drops the bishop back with some
sort of equal position Bishop C4 is the
engine move counter-attacking the Knight
yeah things get very complicated here
but black is not worse Black is not
worse so the key for our opponent would
have been to go Knight P6 immediately
that just shows you the level of
subtlety that accompanies lines at this
level
so but hopefully everybody understood
the logic
okay so our opponent decided to take on
B5 first and that is what gave us the
big Advantage Bishop B7 now I decided on
the Move Bishop E3 and perhaps my other
candidate move would have been a little
bit more to the point which was Bishop
F4 with the idea of meeting Knight B6
with D6 this also now that I look at
this after the game this seems very very
appealing to White and I think white is
clearly better here as well obviously if
black takes
then we take back with the bishop
and at the end The Rook on f8 is going
to be trapped this is not acceptable
so I think Bishop F4 is is perhaps even
more precise but Bishop B3 looks pretty
good as well
okay Knight B6 made sense just to
reiterate why Bishop C6 is a bad move
here black can play Queen B6
as I pointed out during the game the
last thing that we want is to help
Black's Queen get to this ideal square
and ultimately we probably will end up
losing the D5 Pawn here so don't be
Hasty develop your pieces Bishop B3 and
Knight B6 this really transitions the
game from I think the positional phase
to the Tactical phase Bishop takes C5 we
take the second Pawn black picks up D5
we trade and we play Bishop D4 and in
retrospect I do think that E5 is
probably a mistake it's an incredibly
creative move and kudos to our opponent
for finding it but probably White's
Advantage could have been minimized if
black had played Knight F4 which is what
I think black should have done now my
plan here was to trade on G7
and actually to avoid taking on d8 right
because if you take on d8 here black
gets The Rook to an open file black even
has the possibility of trading on F3 and
infiltrating the second rank so I think
keeping the tension here with the move
like A4 would give white a big Advantage
this is what I would have done a move
like A4 and I think white is clearly
better but the game continues black is
quite active
but I know that this is pretty technical
so let's really get to the fun part of
the game let's discuss the position
after Queen G5 so takes
takes takes and first and foremost the
move Queen G5 had to be examined Bishop
C6 is a critical resource I think
without this resource Black's initiative
would have been successful maybe we also
have Knight F3 but Bishop C6 is
definitely the best move I just checked
with the engine it wins the game black
Black's initiative evaporates
again Queen E5 Bishop B7 we can also
trade the bishop for the Knight and in
the event of the trade black is no more
attack Knight F4 simply Queen F3 that's
it there's no way to even create a
threat against White's King
if black players Rook ae8 the engine
actually says you can start pushing
there is no attack to speak of 92 check
is just one check it doesn't do anything
you cannot dislodge the queen from F3 a
rookie 3 would be awesome but there's a
Pawn on F2 that's protecting that square
so just because it's the middle game and
this is another common misconception
doesn't mean that past pawns can't be
promoted with the Queens on the board
they absolutely can be right so the plan
here for white is A4 B4 or just push the
a pawn all the way down to A7 because
that's a protected Square
so in any case Queen F6 is a lovely idea
by our opponent inducing Knight D7 and
now bringing the queen to G5 and here it
was crucial for us to find Queen F3 so
once again why not Knight takes f8 apart
from Knight E3 even more decisive is
Knight F4 this is literally Checkmate in
three moves because G2 is under Fire and
white is no way to defend it and if G3
and the Knight H3 is made white has to
Stave It Off by playing Bishop C6 and
then Queen F3 that tells you all you
need to know
so Queen F3 is I think a very
instructive move and
as I mentioned during the game the way
you find these types of moves is you
realize that a pin or an x-ray is a
two-way street particularly if the piece
that's quote-unquote giving the X-ray
the piece of lower value is also
undefended the queen can be just as much
of an aggressor as the bishop can
and it's important that black can't
bring the Rook to B8 that square is
protected by the Knight so the bishop
will remain undefended on the next move
so black plays Rook fc8 which I think is
is virtually forced and Harold Lloyd
asks can you analyze Rook fd1 instead of
A4 so I I'm proud of A4 I think this is
a very calm move
which just improves the position because
black has no threat
Harold suggested Rook F to D1 which I
also really like I actually think this
is a great move and black has a hard
time stopping This brilliant threat of
the double capture on D5 even if
blackface Rook C2 you can still take on
D5 I think
Bishop D5 Queen D5 Queen D5 Knight F6
and then the resulting end game
white should definitely be winning here
especially because black is unable I
think to win the A2 Pawn otherwise that
should be a draw
if Rook A4
who can tell me how white keeps
everything alive what is and I just
checked at the engine this is a very
important resource for white otherwise
the A2 Pawn is lost
don't go Bishop E3 and blunder to Rook
takes B3 so that's what it's not 93 only
move retreating Night Moves Knight
defends the bishop Bishop defends the
pawn and the Knight is on a defended
Square
also don't go Rook C1 because of the
back rank trick with Rook takes C4
so your move Herald would be fantastic
as well Rook fd1 I was like irrationally
worried about black bringing the king up
to G7 and I was also reticent about
going for this position because I
thought maybe I'm miscalculating
something maybe there's some back rank
check I wasn't totally sure
and I thought that A4 was a safer option
in time pressure because this basically
guarantees that everything is protected
and you know moves like A4
are hard to find especially when there's
a lot going on there's a lot of traffic
in the position finding a quiet move
that improves your position is hard from
a psychological standpoint as well
because you feel like you need to do
something
the way that you find these types of
moves is that you first and foremost
need to figure out whether there is an
actual threat right that's the first
thing I asked myself does lack of a
threat the answer is no because there's
no Discovery we take the bishop in all
of the cases notice that if black plays
Knight E3 we don't take the Knight we
still take the bishop
and here we can we can take on F1 but
even better is to take the Rook nf8 so
there is literally nothing that black
can do to us I wanted to play Knight B6
this is a really creative idea but it
fails because after Knight B6 Queen B7
guess what the bishop on B5 is hanging
that's actually how I found the movie A4
and I thought wait a second if we play
A4 to support the bishop not only does
that you know relieve our burden on the
queen side it makes this Knight B6 idea
possible against a lot of options like
if black makes a random move Knight B6
is an excellent move because it Forks
the Rooks and it forces black to give up
his only active piece and here white is
simply winning
so that was part of the reason that I
played A4 big part of the reason and of
course the fact that it pushes the past
Pawn which is good in and of itself
hopefully the reasoning makes sense
I had other candidate moves here I was
seriously contemplating as you guys know
rook fe1 and the reason I rejected it is
because of Rook C2 and at this point
black has some crazy tactical ideas
here I got scared because at first I
thought we could still play Knight B6
but no takes and again the bishop hangs
that's not still not possible and if you
play a move like A4 black can already
make a draw or come very close to making
a draw who can spot the tactic that
black now has which becomes a lot
stronger with the Rook now sitting on C2
what can black now do that previously
LED nowhere
very nice dark tiger got it Knight F4 is
correct now what's the chief difference
the difference is that here white no
longer has the move King F1 because Rook
takes F2 his Checkmate compare that to
this position here King F1 is not only
winning but it's the only move and F2 is
protected but with the Rook on C2
King F1 is not possible black white has
to Quick King H1 and black is able to
repeat moves and it's a miracle that
black is in mating white this is a drop
and this is the concept that just
because an idea doesn't work in one
position doesn't mean that it doesn't
work in another you have to constantly
update your perception of the board any
any time any piece moves to a more
active Square you need to reassess and
reevaluate a lot of the key tactical
ideas which you know are you know need
to be carefully calculated Knight F4 is
an obvious move so you have to keep
considering it because things might have
changed imperceptibly with the Rook
let's say coming to C2 and again I
definitely have some examples of this
type of thinking leading to a blunder
not thinking in this way
but I'd have to think about it and I
think we've done enough
so every move yeah you have to update
the board state but you can only do it
so much especially in a Blitz game right
you can't spend five minutes reassessing
and recalculating but it's a lot easier
at times to do that than it seems here
it's quite easy because you know exactly
what the Rook is doing and if you pay
attention to the right factors you'll
understand that Knight F4 a much more
powerful threat this time
once we finish the game I'll see if I
can come up with some examples okay so
A4 was played our opponent plays Rook C2
and now I went for the Practical option
of Queen G3
now turning on the engine yields some
crazy stuff according to the engine we
should have stuck with the Rook 81 idea
and after Rook takes B2 you guys know
the drill Rook takes D5 is the simplest
and you don't even need Queen takes D5
you can actually just deliver the check
immediately and the Queen's on the board
favor white because Black's King is in
huge trouble
so Rook a D1 for some reason did not
occur to me because I was very worried
about Knight F4 oh but of course now now
the king can go to H1 and after Knight
takes F2 you can take it and that is why
you bring put the a rook on D1 and not
the F Rook right that's the difference
here Knight F4 makes a draw this is like
what it comes down to when you got these
tactical games these small subtle
differences but all of it can be
understood right it's it's logical it's
just hard to see during the game
um but also intuitively I would play
Rook 81 because I wouldn't move Pieces
away from the king with all of black
spaces trained at the king
um and after Rook 81 if black plays King
G7 our old friend makes an appearance
Knight B6 again
and again the genius of May 4 now shines
through because we never have to worry
about the hanging Bishop this is why
undefended pieces are so freaking uh you
know potentially fatal
and conversely why keeping her pieces
defended by pawns often allows you to
benefit in these tactical sequences
so we played Queen G3 I think our
opponent had to trade I don't think
there was an alternative and what I
overlooked is of course that after
Bishop C8 Bishop C6 I overlooked the
move Rook A5 otherwise black loses at
least in exchange here black counter
attacks the Knight and if the Knight
drops back then The Rook defends the
other night
so it's important that black has this
move because there's no alternative the
bishop is trapped and if black had
played Rook A7 then we take the bishop
and Fork The Rook in the Knight with
Bishop C6 this I saw
this I saw great job by our opponent
spotting the Tactical detail and now I
think I did something that I'm pretty
proud of because we had only a minute
30. I think a lot of players in general
when you're banking on something you've
calculated a sequence and then suddenly
you realize that you had overlooked
something right it's very important not
to just sort of stubbornly play the move
anyway I think a lot of flares you might
relate to this I've done this before
where you almost don't want to believe
that the move doesn't work and so you
dig yourself into the hole because
you're too lazy to look for other
options but it's important to admit to
yourself as quickly as possible yes I
overlooked this move yes this actually
makes things worse for white because if
the Knight has to drop back then black
Strokes now get active and White's
Advantage virtually evaporates
so you have to double back put a stop to
it and and say okay I'm not playing
Bishop C6 how can I improve my position
and once you phrase it like that I think
it's obvious that The Rook from F1 needs
to get into the game Rook fc1 is a very
natural move Rook fd1 I think would have
also been a very good move
I was worried about Knight C3
but apparently this position is good for
white I just checked the engine and the
pin against the bishop is very strong
but this is kind of hard to evaluate
and I thought Rook fc1 is a harder move
to face practically because it restricts
the Knight it defends the C3 Square and
black could have maintained drawing
chances here with the move Knight before
the engine gives about plus two it's
still definitely a winning end game we
would have traded the other rook and I
don't think this is defensible from a
human standpoint also because the Knight
has to go back to A6
now of course there's Bishop C6 and
Knight B3 very similar to what we did in
the game
our opponent hastened his defeat with
Bishop F5 now again just because the
move doesn't work in one position does
it mean you have to stop checking it
that's why we played Rook fc1 to protect
the Knight taking the sting out of Rook
A5 and luckily we have this move Knight
B7 dislodging The Rook from d8
dislodging The Rook from d8 okay and
that ends the game because
okay the best that black can do is to
give up the exchange but without the a
pawn there would be technique required
with the a pawn this is Elementary win
Elementary win okay so I wish I had some
ready-made examples of some of the the
principles that we outlined but still
we've done a lot of analysis in this
game so I think that will be sufficient
any questions because there there's a
lot a lot that we talked about we
covered the theory which was Queen A4
check We examined
sort of typical banco-like ideas the
black has to carry out in order to
equalize just for the sake of
completeness the Banco Gambit which I
should have showed earlier is D4 net of
64 C5 this is the entry point to the
benoni E6 is the modern benoni where
black fianchetto's the bishop but Banco
is B5 also called the Volga Gambit in
Russia B5 so you sacrifice the pawn and
then typically you play the move A6 and
here you can see the similarity in the
structure
in the sense that black has the open a
and b files that he will try to use to
put pressure on White's Queen side and
usually
the dark squared Bishop is fee and get
out here
and that's
about it white does not have to play ba
by the way in the Bank of white off and
sacks the pawn back with a move like B6
to keep the queen side closed so the
benko is an incredibly complex opening
in its own right
but black had to demonstrate those ideas
in order to equalize ASAP so our
opponent didn't play B5 we could have
prevented it with A4 on several
different occasions and here the big
mistake was to play the automatic move
which helps our Bishop get active an ip6
seems to equalize for black then later
um fast forwarding to the next important
moments we kind of initiate a series of
Trades so kind of knowing what you want
to accomplish is important and not
buying your opponent's Bluff right
Bishop E5 Queen G5 looks very scary but
you calculate one move further and then
you find Bishop C6
and once again here as well it seems
like the move Knight D7 fails but you
don't have to assume that Knight takes
f8 is force you have to look for other
moves Queen F3 comes to the rescue and
the rest was pretty smooth we're getting
some questions about a couple different
opening lines remember that there will
be dedicated YouTube videos on all of
the allopin lines okay so that's
separate from the speed run I will cover
the theory in a series of videos
including the move E5 which we have not
faced what is a recommendation of some
YouTubers definitely need to know how to
respond white can get an advantage here
so it's not the end of the world but you
can wait for those and hopefully will
face more theoretically testing alopin
lines during the speed run
and have a great start to your weekend
everybody thanks for hanging out
[Music]